et nous avons rencontré en fait samedi
dernier sainte Séverino qui était en
concert à Maurepas donc son dernier
album onky Tonk qui est sorti en mars
dernier signe en fait une nouvelle
couleur musicale c'est un nouveau
registre dans lequel on ne le
connaissait pas sans se faire une nous
en parle on les côtes
actuellement en tournée pour la sortie
de votre dernier album qui s'appelle
que l'album sert à faire une tournée en
fait c'est l'inverse alors
c'est c'est comment dire la journée sert
pas à défendre l'album c'est l'album
sert de base à la tournée c'est
l'inverse
tout de suite et alors du coup ce soir
pour la fête de la ville à Maurepas qui
est en concert vous allez présenter
quelques titres tout l'album tout
l'album peu de chose en fait je fais ça
à chaque fois c'est à dire que les
albums servent à changer les spectacles
c'est pour ça que que que les albums
servent à tourner et pas l'inverse c'est
à dire c'est l'occasion de renouveler
tout le répertoire et de faire
a priori 80 % de nouvelles chansons la
musique que j'utilise pour cet album
ouais ça fait partie de la country et du
folk il y a pas de batterie il y a pas
d'instruments électriques c'est avec
ouais ouais quand même ouais ouais il y
a un bonjour violon mandoline
contrebasse et guitare voilà et c'est
c'est ça c'est quand même faut respecter
ses lois c'est un peu comme le temps en
gros s'il y a pas de bandonéon c'est dur
de reconnaître le son elle a le blog
grâce s'il y a pas de banjo 5 cordes et
et de mandoline
c'est limite donc voilà il y a
je connais ça depuis que j'ai
on sait rien ça fait trop longtemps que
je connais le Blue grave quoi j'avais
découvert ça quand j'avais 20 ans et
puis voilà j'ai toujours
jazz manouche on va dire mais ça ça a
duré que jusqu'à 2006 et j'ai changé en
concert et en album à partir de 2006
c'est-à-dire donc il y a bientôt 5 ans
et j'ai fait donc deux albums de swing
et les trois après on utilise les albums
avec des sons différents à chaque fois
et on a vu l'évolution
aujourd'hui blue grasse
plus que des évolutions parce que
sinon c'est pas très dur je risque le
ridicule en gros c'est pas très grave je
veux dire change le son pour un album
voilà je peux le premier à faire ça les
groupes généralement font pas ça les
groupes ils gardent leur même son tout
le temps et puis il y a des chanteurs
qui qui aiment bien aussi garder leur
son et d'album en album pour que les
gens les reconnaissent tout le temps
puis eux c'est le truc qu'ils aiment et
moi j'aime bien changer maintenant à
chaque fois et me plonger dans un
univers
je connais quand même mais qui qui qui
qui
sont partis de je sais pas de ma culture
quoi je suis censé quand même
montrer et faire écouter aux gens les
musiques que j'aime et pas garder juste
un des trucs quels sont les retours du
public qui qui vous suit là sur du coup
avec ces derniers concerts
et ben les retours ils sont très
positifs c'est-à-dire que les gens à la
limite ils se demandent pas quel nom ça
a nickel musique c'est tout il voit le
chanteur qu'ils aiment bien et puis ils
sont contents du spectacle ou pas
de la musique acoustique par rapport aux
deux tournées d'amour qui étaient très
électriques il y a beaucoup quand même
beaucoup plus de gens qui qui
reconnaissent les textes un peu mieux
c'est vrai qu'il y a moins d'espace dans
une musique électrique enfin une musique
électrique jouer forte
un peu moins de place pour les textes
mais là là il y a de nouveau plein de
pinceaux les gens sont assez contents et
puis je pense que les gens ils aiment
bien cette musique là qui est en fait
assez c'est de la musique assez
improvisée le Blue grâce à il y a pas
beaucoup de l'école c'est quand même tel
couplet c'est toi qui joue derrière tel
couplet c'est toi ensuite on a une intro
enfin ça ressemble un peu rock'n'roll
par certains points c'est à dire que
c'est ça a pas l'air à ranger dans le
sens il y a pas d'arrangement il y en a
toujours quelques-uns un peu mais c'est
c'est pas mal une musique de bar quand
même c'est à dire que c'est fait pour
pour c'est pas fait pour danser mais on
peut taper du pied et taper des doigts
et des mains quand même et et
moi je trouve ça enfin moi j'adore ça
mais mais j'ai l'impression que les gens
ils
trouvent ça c'est assez positif et et
je sais pas porteur de de trucs sympas
quoi en tout cas
est-ce que on parlait des textes
justement est-ce qu'on retrouve dans
cette drôle décalé parfois un peu
corrosif c'est toujours moi qui l'ai
fait alors forcément ils sont un peu
comme tu dis mais
je pense que ça moi je peux pas faire
autrement par contre je peux changer les
sons des albums et puis prendre un
guitariste ou un batteur différent ou
alors un arrangeur qui va me mettre que
de l'électro ou je ne sais quoi pour
faire un album avec la caravane passe
et qu'on entend derrière j'aurais
toujours mes textes avec moi du coup on
reconnaîtra toujours ça c'est l'avantage
d'être chanceux bon il y a des messages
moi j'ai l'impression que j'ai plus de
messages dans le concert que dans les
albums les messages c'est quand même un
peu toujours les mêmes c'est quand même
un peu moins gros con quoi
je verrai bien merci